une caverne d'ali baba pour enfants
situé à versailles difficile de se
frayer un chemin au milieu de ces
joujoux par milliers puzzles jeux de
société figurines en bois un véritable
paradis du jouet les tout petits mais
les pleins à craquer et on est très bien
conseillé
voilà donc c'est vraiment une boîte à
trésors c'est très condensée mais il ya
beaucoup de choses il ya énormément de
choix catherine est une grande joueuse
et elle connaît tous les jeux et elle
est capable d'identifier le jeu qui
correspond à la bonne terre savez cubes
alors il y en a avec des formes normal
puis on avec des formes un peu un peu
particulière pour s'amuser à faire des
empilages ce magasin est une institution
ouvert en 1972 par pierre de goncourt il
installe un petit train en vitrine qui
fonctionne en appuyant sur un bouton
cette boutique est reprise en 2008 par
catherine signol une passionnée du jouet
il faut aider le client exprimé son
besoin qu est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il
veut pour qui qui s'adresse une fille et
un garçon un petit un grand un adulte
voilà toutes les questions qui vont
permettre de donner le bon conseil à la
bonne personne au bon moment moi j'aime
les belles choses alors je les jouais
mois il faut qu'il soit surtout bas j'ai
très peu joué plastique c'est surtout du
bois j'aime le bois au contact parce que
c'est agréable
ces joujoux qui ont sûrement ravi les
enfants catherine signol peut prendre du
repos pour retrouver le papa noël
l'année prochaine